last week during our vacation bill
oreilly the very popular right-wing TV
personality who for the last 21 years
has been hosting the O'Reilly Factor on
Fox News was fired amid a disgraceful
sexual harassment scandal and Fox News
in general is quickly becoming pretty
notorious for sexual harassment scandals
remember that the last round of sexual
harassment allegations at Fox News were
less than a year ago when a long list of
women came forward accusing Fox News CEO
Roger Ailes of sexual harassment it
resulted in a less being forced to
resign in shame at the beginning of
April a New York Times investigation
discovered that five women who work or
worked for O'Reilly or appeared on his
show over the course of many decades had
been paid off by O'Reilly or by Fox the
state's quiet about their claims which
ranged from just verbal abuse to sexual
comments unwelcome sexual advances as
well as phone calls from O'Reilly where
the women said it sounded like he was
masturbating
while on the phone with them altogether
these women were paid about 13 million
dollars not to sue Bill O'Reilly over
these incidents and a few days after
this came out on April 5th dr. Wendy
Walsh who's a recurring guest on The
O'Reilly Factor also came forward with
allegations against O'Reilly and
recorded her call to the Fox complaint
hotline take a listen to this if you
wish to report a concern please press 3
[Music]
yes
in 2013 I experienced sexual harassment
as a job applicant at Fox News Channel
by an employee named mr. Bill O'Reilly
right and when he turned around to find
me he said no let's go to my suite and I
said I'm sorry I can't do that
and he said okay so we went into the bar
and very soon he became hostile
he said insulting things to me yeah so
this went on 21st Century Fox received
enormous backlash for initially standing
by O'Reilly during past allegations over
50 companies pulled their ads on The
O'Reilly Factor though and numerous
women at Fox News expressed doubt as to
whether Fox News is committed to
maintaining a safe and healthy work
environment for women the public
pressure began and ultimately Bill
O'Reilly while he was on vacation
actually Fox sent out a statement saying
Bill O'Reilly is not going to be
returning to the Fox News Channel they
sent this out to their employees
internally saying that they did a
thorough and careful review of the
allegations Pat I'm devastated by this
who's going to fight back against the
war on Christmas now that Bill O'Reilly
isn't at Fox News anymore that's just
gonna be waged out completely unfettered
Tucker Carlson's going to have to take
over with that regard and notice how
this wasn't really much of an issue as
Fox News was concerned until advertisers
pulled pulling their commercials off the
yeah numerous allegations the 15 years
of this happening didn't matter it was
only when they started to take the
commercials away fellow sexual predator
Donald Trump came to Bill O'Reilly's
defense earlier this month he said to
the New York Times quote I think he's a
person I know well he is a good person
I don't think bill did anything wrong of
course Donald Trump would have no idea
whether these allegations against
O'Reilly are true and he's only
defending him because they are friends
and O'Reilly has always gone pretty easy
on Trump here's the real issue though
with the Trump defense of O'Reilly as
far as the public knows Bill O'Reilly
has only been accused of actual sexual
assault once in 2004 now I'm obviously
not minimizing anything that Bill
O'Reilly might have done but my point is
almost all of the sexual misconduct that
O'Reilly has been accused of has been
non-physical sexual harassment and he
was still fired as a television host I'm
not minimizing none
physical sexual harassment I'm saying
O'Reilly was fired for what is mostly
non physical sexual harassment meanwhile
the President of the United States
before he took office had been accused
by over a dozen women of physical sexual
assault his ex-wife accused him of rape
seven women accused Trump of grabbing
grabbing them and kissing them on the
mouth
two women accused Trump of trying to put
his hand up their skirts three women
accused Trump of grabbing their breasts
three women accused Trump of grabbing
their buttocks but not only that Trump
himself admitted that he sexually
assaults women and grabs their genitals
in a video that was public so a
political TV host is accused of sexual
harassment and gets fired from his TV
show and he should have been fired but
then a guy who has a ton of actual
sexual assault allegations against him
allegations that are all consistent very
believable a man who admitted with his
own mouth that yes he gropes women he
gets elected president of the United
States it just goes to show that Bill
O'Reilly and Donald Trump supporters
will defend them no matter what if you
took a look at Bill O'Reilly's ratings
over the past few weeks they were
sky-high now normally he had been the
top-rated cable news host yeah but in
the midst of those allegations and the
scandal and the idea that maybe he could
be fired from Fox News they were at the
highest point but wasn't that because of
people's curiosity about whether maybe
he would comment on the allegations like
I don't think people were all of a
sudden because of what was going on
thinking O'Reilly just as really great
incisive journalism right I if it wasn't
for me I'd be wondering is he gonna
comment on what's going on maybe and I
think there's also just a lot of people
rallying to his side I guess now he's
going to start some sort of podcast but
given that his average age of his
audience is something like 70 right
they're not gonna really tune into that
yeah that's an interesting point and
there was a day a couple weeks ago where
I guess the entire hour of somebody
emailed me saying that there were like
three ads there's some small amount of
ads like it was very noticeable that
tons of ads were just gone from the show
his show got stopped fifteen minutes
early because they just couldn't fill
the air time is that true oh yeah and
what did they go to so I get 45 past the
hour they went to something else they
went to a breaking news update of
something that happened hours before
that day I think on topic of Syria but
it was certainly not breaking news
stunning I missed a lot when I was on
vacation that is that is absolutely
amazing